the saga of the use of chemical weapons
in Syria has been long and horrific but
now finally the results of a technical
investigation that finds the Assad
regime responsible the inquiry by the
International chemical weapons body the
OPCW finds that a lot Amina in hammer
governorate was attacked three times in
march 2017 over a week-long period twice
the Syrian Air Force used bombs
containing sarin this is the aftermath
of the other occasion now patients being
treated for breathing difficulties after
an improvised barrel bomb containing
chlorine was dropped from a Syrian
helicopter onto the hospital in the town
the report will be delivered to the UN
Secretary General Antonio Guterres so
after such clear findings is he now
prepared to directly condemn the Assad
government the secretary-general his
position is unchanged that any it is
intolerable that anyone anywhere use
chemical weapon and impunity for use of
these is equally unacceptable and it's
imperative to identify and hold those
accountable who have used the chemical
weapons so you say it's intolerable for
anyone to do this but the OPCW says that
the Assad government did it will you not
condemn the 'sound gutted government and
why are you playing this lame game of
not taking sides trying to be equal to
both sides aren't you leaving one very
important side out of this and that's
the Syrian people who have been gassed
and over the last 50 years by the Assad
regime have been executed and tortured I
think we are on the front lines with the
Syrian people we have been or
humanitarian colleagues have been there
throughout throughout this conflict
trying to support the Syrian people in
their daily lives so why is the UN
pulling its punches well the answer is
Russia Syria's closest ally and
why you're unlikely to see any
accountability for the attacks in this
report the UN Security Council has tried
to refer Syria to the International
Criminal Court in the past but Russia a
permanent member has used its veto James
BAE's al Jazeera at the United Nations